merci d'avoir accepté de venir cet après
midi devant la commission des lois pour
aborder ensemble le texte exactement la
loi ratifiant l'ordonnancé créant le
code de justice pénale des mineurs
je ne vais pas refaire l'historique mais
parce que mes rappelé qu'une même qu'au
moment où le sénat a eu à connaître de
la loi sur la réforme de la justice
votre prédécesseur ne l'avions évoqué
avec votre prédécesseur la possibilité
de d'évoquer justement de traiter la
question du code de justice pénale des
mineurs
ils nous avaient été ré répondu que non
sur un texte spécifique et qu'on le
verrait un autre moment
c'est à la fin du débat parlementaire
que on nous a demandé finalement
d'habilité le gouvernement à légiférer
par voie d'ordonnancé vous n'y êtes pour
rien monsieur le ministre il ya aucun
doute ce n'est pas ce que je veux dire
monier ne peut rien nous le savons tous
ici dans cet hémicycle
simplement nous avions été quand même on
va dire pas contents de cette façon de
faire on peut tout comprendre mais là on
a été pas très heureux du tout bien nous
revoilà avec maintenant leur donnant ce
qui arrive
je ne refais pas la discussion que nous
avons eue au téléphone la semaine
dernière tous les deux à la suite de
contre il m'arrive parfois de parler à
des membres du gouvernement
en prévision de la mise en oeuvre je n'y
reviens pas mais voilà on s'est expliqué
je souhaite quand même nous souhaitons
c'est pas moi à titre particulier mais
l'institution et le sénat en particulier
la commission des lois spécifiques mois
et on était un peu chagriné voilà je
mens arrête là mais en revanche nous
profitons avec beaucoup d'intérêt de cet
après-midi et de votre présence pour
pouvoir évoquer avec vous ce dossier sur
lequel madame agnès canayer qui est ici
un collègue les rapporteurs et aura sans
doute un certain nombre de questions à
vous poser
et puis les autres collègues aussi vrai
simplement il faut propose de vous
laisser tout de suite la parole monsieur
ministre et puis ensuite quand même
canayer puis les collègues qui le
souhaiteront naturellement monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un honneur pour moi de présenter
devant la commission des lois du sénat
le projet de loi de ratification de
l'ordonnancé du 11 septembre 2019 patent
est partie législative du code de la
justice pénale des mineurs
vous l'avez rappelé merci monsieur le
président je ne suis en rien responsable
de la façon dont ce texte arrive ici
devant le sénat et je ne veux pas je ne
serais pas juste vous l'avez concédé
être le réceptacle de votre courroux sur
cette question bon cette réforme on va
le dire elle est attendue de très longue
date 2007 2008 je suis fier d'en
débattre avec vous c'est un texte qui
était largement concertée par tous les
acteurs de la justice des mineurs
il a été enrichi en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale c'est une
[Musique]
concertation de plus de 10 ans quatre
gardes des sceaux et presqu'autant de
majorité qui ont préparé ce travail de
codification de clarification les
réformes successives se sont se sont
empilées sans cohérence au gré des
alternances politiques transformant
l'ordonance de 45 en un texte dont tous
les professionnels s'accordent à dire
qu'il est devenu illisible
cette réforme longuement mûri et
équilibrée vient maintenant devant vous
et elle parvient à répondre aux attentes
des français
améliorer la procédure pénal applicable
aux mineurs délinquants en renforçant
les principes fondamentaux de
l'ordonance de 45 c'est la primauté de
l'éducatif l'atténuation de la peine la
spécialisation des acteurs bon je veux
commencer par corriger ses cibles
rapidement un certain nombre de choses
entendues çà et là et en particulier au
sujet de mépris au début condescendance
et à quels mots utiliser correctement
ministère de la justice ou moi-même moi
même d'ailleurs pour la chambre rock
nous sommes expliqué monsieur le
président je serais sans doute amené à
fournir d'autre explication mais en
réalité les mêmes car j'ai vu que le
courroux s'était également exprimé à la
télévision et donc j'entends vous
rassurer l'inla l'un des griefs
l'une des préoccupations qui est celle
que j'ai entendu à l'assemblée nationale
que vous entendrez certainement ici au
sénat c'est à ce que les juridictions
sont prêtes au fond alors je vous
répondrais complètement en termes de
moyens en terme d' analyse que j'ai
demandé à mes services juridiction par
juridiction et donc on a souhaité
prévenir des juridictions de la première
mouture du texte en ajoutant j'espère
que tout a été lu je suis même convaincu
tout lt lui que le travail au sénat
devait intervenir alors on a dit que
c'était une circulaire canada dry je
vous ai dit vu son horizon que vous
aviez raison une circulaire qui a
vocation à prévenir les professionnels
de ce que un texte va arriver il sera
évidemment amodiés transformez vous
ferez le travail législatif que vous
avez à faire et je l'écris dans cette
circulaire je dis que c'est pas terminé
et que c'est pas sur la base de ce texte
là que les juridictions vont travailler
mais j'ai quand même la secrète
espérance que les grands équilibres ne
seront pas modifiés je les cuis en
toutes lettres donc ça n'était pas pour
moi une volonté de ne pas regarder le
sénat comme il doit l'être
je respecte évidemment la haute
assemblée et j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler avec elle j'espère bien sûr
qu' il ne s'agit pas là d'une polémique
politicienne nous avons eu déjà des
débats parfois nous étions d'accord
parfois nous étions s'opposer je n'ai
jamais souhaité y mettre une dose de
politique politicienne je pense que la
qualité de nos échanges s'en sont
trouvés sans doute amélioré à défaut
d'être déjà de bon niveau et j'entends
naturellement que nous nous poursuivions
sûr sur cette voie alors cette réforme
ceci étant et on précisé elle consacre
une justice des mineurs plus efficace
plus lisible plus rapide et est
désormais prévisible pour tous
l'intervention judiciaire éducative
interviendra plus vite c'est important
parce que nous savons que nombre de
mineurs ont été condamnés après être
majeur et parfois
encore jeune majeur mais mais très très
vieux mineur si vous me permettez cette
expression on est dans des situations
qui sont invraisemblables la mise en
examen n'était enserré par aucun délai
ce qui d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon a
permis le stock c'est le ce mot néo
capitalistique que l'on utilise pardon
je ne les ai pas inventés et vous avez
des gamins de 16 ans qui ont été jugés
quand il en avait 22
c'est une perte de temps pour tout le
monde et il a monde message pédagogique
n'a plus aucune signification il doit
intervenir vite c'est le ministre de la
justice qui vous le dit mais vous le
savez il suffit d'être père de famille
pour le savoir une sanction ou une
mesure éducative d'ailleurs que l'on
inflige que l'on impose à ses enfants
elle intervient pas trois ans après leur
rapidité de la première intervention
judiciaire avec une audience de
culpabilité il signifie pas la mise en
place d'une justice expéditive j'ai pu
lire un certain nombre de chose de cet
ordre de cette nature je le répète les
équilibres sont préservés il ya le temps
de l'éducatif n'est pas réduit il est au
contraire ont cadré il peut être
prolongé lorsque jugé nécessaire et le
travail éducatif s'inscrit bien dans un
continuum donc on a une première
audience de culpabilité puis une
audience qui sera consacré à la peine et
autres les deux des mesures éducatives
et le regroupement de toutes les autres
procédures en cours ça le mérite de la
rapidité et c'est extrêmement important
pour la justice des mineurs
ça prend en compte évidemment les
victimes l'éducatif est au coeur de
cette réforme et je voudrais en deux
secondes et ensuite nous échangeons vaut
pas qu'il se soit à un monologue imposé
je veux clarifier les étapes d'abord
nous pouvons dire que il ya eu un
véritable débat démocratique
ratification par voie d'ordonnancé j'ai
entendu monsieur le président ce que
vous disiez mais le débat démocratique a
été totalement intégré et vous en êtes
d'ailleurs les gants il ya près d'un
demi millier d'amendements qui ont été
discutés en commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale et autant en
séance publique en décembre dernier une
autre était plus de nous est soumise ces
les juridictions et services de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
seront ils prêts alors la réponse elle
est clairement oui mais d'abord je tiens
à vous dire que toutes les réformes ont
souvent été pour ne pas dire toujours
mal perçue est mal reçue j'ai le
souvenir de la loi du 15 juin 2000 dite
loi guigou qui aujourd'hui ne serait
plus discutés par personne il faisait
l'objet de manifestations devant la
chancellerie place vendôme et je me
souviens d'un certain nombre d'acteurs
judiciaire qui jetait les codes et jeté
par terre
j'étais un otage avait persiflé à
l'époque que on ferait mieux de les lire
que de les jeter
il n'y a pas de réformes qui ont été
accueillis les bras ouverts c'est
toujours compliqué une référence ça
c'est sur ce qui s'est passé depuis
toujours historiquement je pense pas
avoir tort maintenant de façon de façon
plus précise
il ya des moyens et des renforts de
moyens nous avons dans les juridictions
d'abord l' expertise des services
il y avait une dizaine de juridiction
qui se trouvait en fragilité elles ont
été analysés d'abord répertoriés
analysés dans les juridictions nous
avons envoyé 72 magistrats qui ont été
affectés au 1er septembre 2020 sans
greffier qui ont permis un renfort
immédiat en anticipant évidemment les
sorties d'école de greffe je voudrais
vous donner un exemple la localisation
de quatre emplois de greffe depuis 2018
à bobigny répondant ainsi aux demandes
exprimées par les chefs de juridiction
au sein de la pjj la réforme a également
été anticipé depuis 2018
avec 252 emplois nouveaux prêts
jusqu'en 2022 en complément quatre-vingt
six éducateurs viennent d'être recrutés
dans le cadre des budgets qui ont été
alloués à la justice de proximité un
appui inédit naturellement légitime et
grâce à cette mission que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure de l'inspection générale
de la justice nous avons pu apporter aux
juridictions et aux services
territoriaux de la pjj une assistance
méthodologique direct à la mise en place
de la réforme donc j'affirme que les
juridictions sont prêtes à recevoir et à
appliquer cette réforme
nous avons d'ailleurs sur le terrain
numérique anticiper sa mise en oeuvre de
façon bien sûr à ce que les dispositions
nouvelles soient plus rapides monte
intégré longtemps j'entends maintenant
si vous voulez bien que nous échangions
sur ces questions il ya un certain
nombre de problèmes qui ont notamment
été évoqué à l'assemblée nationale qui
seront peut-être affectés ici devant le
sénat je pas monopoliser la parole
notre temps est un peu compté monsieur
le président si je comprends bien donc
je souhaite plutôt et si vous le voulez
bien que que nous échangions sur les
équilibres nouveaux apportés par cette
loi et je suis à votre entière
disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
questions
merci monsieur le ministre oui nous
avons le temps devant nous il ya pas
trop de difficultés particulières
madame agnès canayer merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
alors effectivement nous ne contestons
pas la nécessité de la mise en oeuvre de
cette réforme qui est attendue étant
donné que l' ordonnance de 1945 a été
réformé plus de 40 fois et que l'on voit
bien aujourd'hui un certain décalage est
une nécessité de rendre quand vous
l'avez et annoncé une justice plus
adaptée à l'évolution et au besoin des
démineurs néanmoins un certain nombre de
questions se posent à nous et la
première vous avez commencé à l'aborder
c'est avant tout celle des délais
d'entrée en vigueur
de cette réforme qui nous paraissent
dans le temps que nous connaissons dans
le contexte que nous vivons actuellement
notamment et celui des juridictions qui
supportent cette crise comme nous tous
cette crise sanitaire et ses effets qui
a supporté une grève des avocats qui a
quand même ralenti aussi un certain
nombre de procédures et augmenter un
certain nombre de stocks nous étant
effectivement pas très beau mais
représentant le nombre de dossiers quand
on a la cote en se rendant les tribunaux
on voit effectivement six tomes de
dossiers papier qui s'empilent et ça une
vraie réalité et donc nous voyons
aujourd'hui quand même que cette mise en
oeuvre à délais très rapprochés puisque
31 mars sera un mois au mieux après la
fin du processus législatif alors on a
bien compris que vous l'aviez anticipé
ce qui en soi est compréhensible
néanmoins on voit bien que ça risque
d'être quand même très compliqué alors
peut considérer que la technique du
sparadrap c'est efficace coup ça fait
mal et et au moins comme ça on rentre
directement dans le vif du sujet
néanmoins là il me semble quand même que
certains nombre de juridictions ne sont
pas prêtes pour pouvoir assimiler cette
réforme quand bien même des moyens
supplémentaires ont été mis en oeuvre on
a eu ces débats au moment où du projet
de loi de finances néanmoins on voit
qu'il ya quand même encore un certain
nombre de l'addiction qui sont en
fragilité pour lesquelles ça risque
compliqué d'être compliqué dans ce délai
raccourci de mettre en place non
seulement parce que tous les stocks ne
seront pas à apurer parce que la période
de transition où moment il faudra pour
ces juridictions assimilés 2
procédure l'ancienne et la nouvelle
n'est pas forcément toujours bien encore
préparé techniquement et même
juridiquement parce qu'on sent que la
formation et l'information voire
l'information pour certains acteurs de
cette gestion des mineurs est pas tout à
fait encore assuré et les parle
complètement affiné et on voit surtout
que les moyens informatiques vous l'avez
évoluer époque et notamment aux
cassiopée est loin d'être au point on le
sait pour d'autres réformes que la
difficulté
damman que ce soit la réforme du divorce
ou celle du bloc pen reste encore
compliqué à mettre en place faute de
moyens informatiques
donc ma question va être simple c'est
comment entendez vous tenir ce délai
quels moyens alors j'ai compris compris
des moyens humains mais ça va pas
suffire mais s'il suffit pas d'avoir des
personnels en nombre il faut aussi des
personnes et des magistrats des
greffiers et des acteurs de la pjj qui
soit optimum est capable d'avoir
assimilé la réforme qui est quand même
une réforme d'ampleur
on parle pas d'une petite réforme de
procédure on parle de la réforme globale
de l'ensemble du code pénal des mineurs
avec vous l'avez dit une procédure
innovante avec cette procédure de la
césure enfin qu'il change totalement les
pratiques de cette justice pénale des
mineurs
et donc nous sommes extrêmement inquiet
aujourd'hui sur une mise en oeuvre à
délai rapproché qui pour nous va
fragiliser les fondations d'une réforme
qui est importante et qui est essentiel
est qu on a manifestement et a fortiori
dans le contexte dans lequel nous vivons
besoins et les auditions besoin d'un
délai supplémentaire sans remettre en
cause la réforme mais vraiment pour
renforcer sa mi temps de ça c'est une
première question
deuxième question c'est on voit que
c'est une réforme d'une partie
simplement de la justice des mineurs
celle de la partie pénale
or le mineur avec un principe
fondamental qui est celui de l'éducatif
qui doit primer sur le répressif mais
dès lors que l'on aborde l'éducatif on
doit prendre l'enfant dans toutes ses
composantes et on sait qu'il y a de fort
rapprochement il dans les dossiers entre
les problématiques de l'enfance
délinquante et de celle de l'enfance en
danger et donc comment penser quels
moyens entendez-vous m comment
entendez-vous mieux articuler ces deux
parties indissociables de la justice des
mineurs
celle la partie éducative et la partie
pénale
une troisième question va concerner les
mineurs non accompagnés qui est un sujet
en soi dans le sujet et notamment avec
une procédure qui leur est adapté celle
de l'audience unique
ma question est simple aussi cette
pensez vous vraiment que cette mesure va
être adapté à des mineurs non
accompagnés qui sont pris dans des
réseaux parce qu'on voit beaucoup aussi
difficultés sur ces mineurs particulier
qui se retrouvent happés par des réseaux
et qui sont difficilement à la mesure et
à la disposition de la justice
notre question sur le recours au juge de
la liberté et des détentions
donc je vais qui est un sujet qui nous
pose problème aussi alors qui a été
ajouté par l'assemblée nationale pour
répondre au respect des principes
d'impartialité du juge tels que imposée
par le conseil constitutionnel en
application de l'accord aux pensions
européenne des droits de l'homme
comment voyez vous cette articulation
avec la justice des mineurs notamment le
fait que le juge des mineurs n'est plus
présent dans cette partie celle de la
détention et de la liberté la mise en
liberté du mineur alors qu'il doit pour
nous avoir aussi une continuité
éducative sur ce sujet et j'ai un autre
question concernant qui puisque un des
enjeux aussi la spécialisation et la
spécifité des jeux et diction or vous
avez maintenu dans ce code de justice
pénale des mineurs
la compétence du tribunal de police pour
les contrats handicap mais conversion
des quatre premières classes nous paraît
être un peu anachronique avec la volonté
de spécialisation pas très opportun que
ce soit le juge des enfants ou le
tribunal pour enfants enfin justice des
mineurs qui soit compétente dans sa
globalité
puis une dernière question là aussi ce
nous
les la volonté d'une justice plus rapide
pour mieux répondre au développement de
l'enfant et mieux prendre en compte les
victimes nous paraît opportun sont
pourtant les délais sont des délais
indicatif
comment comptez vous assurez le
véritablement respect de ces délais
contraints dans cette procédure
hall tout de suite à monsieur jean
pierre sueur qui la demandaient puis
ensuite mais que le comte merci monsieur
le président à mameria voulait à à bon
port par adacore aussi bon pas de
difficultés particulières
le mieux c'est une fois une réponse
globale est alors voulu répondre à
porter en premier c'est monsieur sûr
mais merci monsieur le président
continue alors monsieur le garde des
sceaux
je voulais d'abord posé une question qui
n'a pas qui n'a pas très exactement à ce
texte mais qui a trait l'urgence vous
savez que le conseil constitutionnel a
demandé avec beaucoup de force
d'ailleurs les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel s'imposent à toutes les
autorités comme vous savez qu'il y ait
eu un texte législatif par rapport à la
possibilité donnée aux détenus de
contester leurs conditions de détention
pour indignité
vous aviez pensé vous nous l'aviez
d'ailleurs indiqué présenter ce texte à
la faveur du projet de loi sur le
parquet puis vous y avait renoncé
craignant que cela ne fût considéré
comme un des innombrables cavaliers bien
mais alors je vous demande simplement à
quelle date pour comptait déposer un
projet doigt parce qu'il ya deux
solutions ou via une proposition de loi
mais sans le concours du gouvernement je
vois mal qu'elle puisse être appliquée
adopté avant avec deux navettes avant le
mois de mars est donc il reste une pour
un projet de loi et si comme on ne peut
pas ne pas appliquer ce que dit le
conseil constitutionnel
je me permets aujourd'hui 13 janvier de
vous poser la question même si elle ce
n'est pas le sujet de la réunion du jour
parce qu'il faudra bien trouver une
solution alors pour ce qui est du texte
madame canayer a déjà posé beaucoup de
question que je voulais aborder et à
juste titre donc le premier point je
vais aborder trois points seulement le
premier point c'est en effet la date
d'application
compte tenu de ce que vous nous avez dit
je ne vais pas revenir sur le fait que
le texte d'application ce au préalable
sur balles au sénat etc du texte vous
avez déjà répondu est ce qui ne serait
pas sage de reporter la date
d'application tout simplement de
quelques mois pour le mois de manière à
ce que l'on se peut que les que les
différentes personnes responsables de ce
sujet dans les juridictions puisse se
préparer
deuxième question nous avons longuement
parlé l'autre jour avec jean pierre rose
avec kinder dû parler en bien de vous
monsieur le ministre mais il nous a dit
de toutes les manières possibles qu'il
était vraiment incompréhensible que l'on
ne pose pas l'irresponsabilité pénale
des mineurs de 13 ans vous savez ce
débat sur la présomption simple laquelle
vous tenez beaucoup si je comprends vous
tenez dans ce texte ou pas subsister
beaucoup ou irréfragable en tout cas
quand on regarde la convention heureux
internationale des droits de l'enfant
que vous connaissez ce serait quand même
pas mal qu'on soit en conformité avec
elles ou avec aussi ce que dit la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme donc
sur 7
oui enfin ce qu'elle dit bon d'accord
mais vous allez répondre monsieur le
mini jupe devant autrement que par votre
port de tête très très harmonieux
d'ailleurs c'est très bien mais toujours
est il que c'est la deuxième fois cette
question là vous le savez se pose de
manière centrale
nous avons reçu les représentants des
magistrats les représentants des avocats
des éducateurs cette question revient
toujours
et enfin dernière question pour ne pas
être trop long ce que vous dites fin bon
l'idée de la césure est une bonne idée
parce que ça permet de prendre une
première décision dans des délais
rapides ce qui est nécessaire
s'agissant des mineurs de donner à
l'acte éducatif toute sa place et
d'avoir ensuite une autre décision bien
nous ne contestons pas cela par contre
monsieur le ministre pour les réitérant
alors là on est dans un système
différent en fait puisque on va arriver
dans quasiment la garde à vue le
déferrement au parquet le centre
éducatif fermé pour les moins de 16 ans
la détention provisoire pour les plus de
16 ans et un tribunal qui va statuer en
une seule fois et donc pour ces jeunes
là ces mineurs là d'une certaine façon
la philosophie générale du texte ne
paraît pas s'appliquer
donc je voulais vous interrogé là-dessus
c'est ma troisième et dernière question
merci messieurs sur la parole et à
monsieur le comte
oui merci monsieur le président moi
aussi je voudrais puisqu'il n'y avait
pas de précision sur le sujet exact de
cette audition sortir un peu de de la
question de l' ordonnance concernant les
la justice des mineurs mais sur la
question des actes de naissance et la
loi bioéthique l'article le cas de
listel qu'il est sorti de l'assemblée
nationale porte une rédaction qui
avaient été portées par le gouvernement
lors de la première lecture au sénat qui
remet en cause l'article 47 du du code
civil qui pose que les actes d'état
civil étranger fouasseau si je résumais
sont notoirement faux et donc ce que la
rédaction qui est proposé dans dans la
loire remet en cause ce principe et vend
registre engendré des des complexités
pour énormément de personnes qui ont eu
des naissances ou des actes d'état civil
enregistrées à l'étranger
pourquoi le gouvernement l'a fait pour
mettre un obstacle est la transcription
des actes de naissance des enfants nés
par gpa à l'étranger
toutefois sur ce sujet
la france a déjà été condamné de
nombreuses fois par le cdh la cour de
cassation a plusieurs fois renforcé
indiqué des ses positions sur le sujet
qui font jurisprudence et le procureur
de la république de nantes a donné des
instructions sur sûr c'est sur ces
questions de manière à ce que les
transcriptions puisse être faite sans
automaticité avec un contrôle renforcé
mais en respectant les exigences de la
cdh de d'effectivité et de célérité
on constate que le ce que vous envisagez
va faire obstacle euros au bureau au pot
à l'exigence de la célérité de qui a été
posé par la cdh et qu'un certain nombre
de situations en particulier pour les
mères seules seront totalement bloquée
parce que nous pourrons pas adopté leurs
propres enfants
ça pose aussi le problème de la
réciprocité des du respect des actes
d'état civil en entre des actes d'état
civil français à l'étranger
donc ma question monsieur le garde des
sceaux c'est est ce que vous êtes à
l'aise avec la rédaction de l'article 4
bis de la loi bioéthique qui est sorti
de l'assemblée nationale et qui est
soumise aujourd'hui un autre assemblée
alors je suis désolé peut-être vous
pensé que c'était juste sur l'autre
thème que vous étiez interrogés mais
rien n'était indiquée dans la
convocation donc et comme nous n'aurons
pas l'occasion de vous interroger sur ce
sujet et sur ce point il me semblait
utile d'avoir votre avis et d'autant que
le sujet biotique n'ai pas pris dans
notre commission faut-il le dire est que
l'objectif de l'audition est
effectivement bien le sujet de la loi
bam hervier non monsieur bah pardon
excusez moi monsieur bah oui monsieur le
président je vous je vous remercie et je
remercie le ministre d'avoir pris les
devants elle de s'être exprimé après
vous monsieur le président et après la
démarche que vous aviez fait sur les
consignes qui ont été adressées par le
garde des sceaux aux juridictions pour
la mise en oeuvre de
cette ordonnance sur la justice des
mineurs sur le garde des sceaux
formalisme est nécessaire à la procédure
judiciaire et il trouve de multiples
points d'application qui doivent tous se
traduire par les applications
informatiques mises en oeuvre par les
greffiers et qui permettent aussi aux
avocats d'ailleurs de suivre l'évolution
d'un dossier
si on règle dans les détails la mise en
oeuvre de l'ordonance avant le vote du
sénat
quelles que soient les langues que les
équipements d'être quelles que soient
les précautions de langage que vous
aurez prises on risque de se trouver
quand même dans une situation où vous
viendrez nous dira dans quelques jours
que vous ne pouvez pas accepter des
amendements même bon du sénat parce que
vous ne pourrez pas tenir votre
calendrier s'ils sont acceptés et nous
avons le sentiment comprenait le jeu
vous je vous explique que notre
motivation est une motivation au four de
qualité du débat parlementaire et de
respect du débat parlementaire et non
pas une préoccupation mais vous ne m'en
avait pas accuser et vous n'en avait
récusé personne de politique
politicienne
si nous ne pouvons pas amender ce texte
parce que les consignes ont déjà été
données pour son application dans un
délai très rapproché ou si nous
n'arrivons pas à un accord en commission
mixte paritaire après nos amendements
pour ce motif qui pourrait être un motif
non dits et bien je regrette de vous
dire que ça constitue quand même un
problème pour les relations entre le
parlement et le gouvernement alors
j'espère tu ne sais plus comment dit en
français que ce n'est pas du wishful
thinking que d'espérer une application
de ce texte
si protéiforme si important si ambitieux
dans un délais aussi rapprochés après le
vote du parlement
et je m'associe à l'interrogation de
notre collègue jean pierre sueur
et d'autres collègues d'ailleurs sur ce
point parce que je crois que quand on
fait une réforme aussi importante il
faut qu il ne manque pas un bouton de
guêtre je comprends que vous avez voulu
travailler en temps masqué je ne leur
reproche pas aux faux vous avez sans
doute eu un souci d'efficacité mais il
vient percuter le débat parlementaire
dans des conditions qui sont tout à fait
inhabituelle je tenais à vous le dire
merci monsieur madame lherbier mais
c'est le président monsieur le garde des
sceaux je voudrais revenir sur l'urgence
vous avez dit intervenir vite dans le
monde de la jeunesse et bien sûr ici
nous en sommes tous absolument convaincu
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur nous a confirmé les chiffres
dramatiques d'augmentation de
maltraitance de violences
intrafamiliales
ces chiffres nous avait déjà été
présenté par les gendarmes par les
procureurs
pendant la période de confinement ces
chiffres dans certains départements sont
extrêmement violents sont extrêmement
importants je suis dit nord est
vous en savez quelque chose on a un
département qui est extrêmement touché
par cette forme de violence familiale
alors je voudrais revenir sur un cas les
suites dramatiques de ces réitération de
violence sans etc forme d'impunité qu'on
rencontre vis-à-vis des parents
quelquefois peuvent être à l'origine de
bien des déstructurations d'enfants
alors aujourd'hui on parle de code de
justice des mineurs
c'est ça mais pour moi toujours
extrêmement douloureux qu'on puisse
s'intéresser aux jeunes quand ils
deviennent délinquants
je trouve qu'on aurait pu le faire bien
en amont pour éviter justement d'en
arriver là
des carences éducatives certes si ça
peut y remédier et tant mieux mais quand
on pense que dans la dans la période de
de détresse de ces enfants les services
d'ailleurs
au sont surchargées que les services de
placements d'enfants sont retardés et il
ya beaucoup de signalements qui ne donne
pas si vite
je trouve bien sûr ce n'est pas
systématique les enfants qui sont en
détresse ne devienne pas délinquants
heureusement mais si on peut les sauver
pour en sauver certains je trouve que
c'est notre responsabilité d'élus notre
responsabilité de juristes alors quand
on voit aussi que quand j'étais adjointe
à sécurité se mette en place des
chantiers tiges les jeunes qui venaient
dans ses chantiers la plupart du temps
c'était la première fois qu'on
s'intéressait à eux c'est la première
fois qu'ils pouvaient montrer qu'on
servait à quelque chose qu'ils savaient
faire des choses des choses que c'est
bien gênant d'associer la sanction à la
halle éducatif il aurait fallu le faire
en amont avant qu'il devienne qu'ils ne
passent à l'acte les services de paie jj
canton les alerter sur des des cas de
détresse
la plupart du temps ils étaient près
récalcitrants à venir participer à nos
réunions de police etc
et je trouve que c'était bien gênant il
avait une suspicion de se dire les élus
ils vont forcément tenir avec les les
jeunes et ils vont forcément être
nuisible aux jeunes et il ne faisait pas
confiance et ça je trouve que c'est
extrêmement dommage parce qu'il faut que
ça soit une amie new que tout le monde
soit solidaire pour sortir les enfants
quand ils peuvent en être sorti de ces
phénomènes
alors bien sûr le code il faut après
être sévère c'est tout ils sont passés à
l'acte qu'il faut punir ça je suis
absolument convaincu mais je profite de
cette de cette rencontre pour aussi
alerter sur ce qui se passe avant et que
je trouve que c'est quand même bien
dommage de le laisser évoluer des choses
très négativement et de d'après de ne
pouvoir que constater merci honneur bien
rien merci monsieur le président donc
beaucoup de questions ont déjà été posés
en moi je vais aller sur une question un
peu plus
technique je vais quand même rebondir je
vais la faire parce que là effectivement
tout le monde l'attend c'est je vais
rebondir donc sur deux remarques de
notre rapporteur la première c'est cathy
op sera t-elle près ça je suis obligé de
le faire
la deuxième c'est concernant les amendes
de police alors je comprends
qu'effectivement les infractions de deux
premières alors justement de 1,4 reste à
la police je me demandais parce que 4e
catégorie 4e classe de première et
quatrième places ça reste à la police et
la cinquième classe passa au juge pour
enfants
6 et est donc en fait le la quatrième
classe qui semble n'être pas forcément
très grave pour un adulte pour un enfant
relève forcément d'un dysfonctionnement
a minima familial et donc mériterait
peut-être de passer plus rapidement vers
le juge pour enfants mais j'ai une
question un peu plus techniques au
moment de la rédaction de l'ordonance
vous aviez prévu dans les modules de
placement qu'un enfant puisse être
placée aussi à la the ce que vous avez
supprimé via un amendement du
gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale en
faisant en sorte que un enfant puisse
être placé dans un cadre familial donc
où c'est une personne de confiance mais
plus à la zone alors je m'interrogeais
mois sur les enfants qui déjà a été
placé à la zone qui ont ce souci là et
donc ça veut dire que parce que je
comprends que des enfants nouveau pas
encore connue et pas encore pris en
charge par le conseil départemental
on ne naît pas les placer à la the dans
une situation de difficulté ça je le
comprends mais par contre un enfant qui
était déjà placé qui va rencontrer une
difficulté comme n'importe quel enfant
de n'importe quelle famille celui là ne
pourra pas être remis dans une famille
comme le premier qui a déjà une famille
m'aide
va forcément aller à la pjj c'est en
quelque sorte une double peine parce
qu'il n'avait pas de famille initial et
donc je sais qu'on peut le placer à la
zone mais que en mode préventive mais
pas au moment de la sanction et du
placement ça c'était c'est dans
l'article l100 12-14
et c'est un amendement qui a été
présentée dans l'article 3 2
10 de la preuve du projet de loi que
nous sommes en train de regarder donc
voilà ma question c'est est-ce qu'un
enfant qui était à la the forcément s'il
a une mesure de placement cette mesure
de placement sera à la pjj est
réellement ne pourra pas être
éventuellement dans une autre famille de
la zone mais encore en cadre familial
merci merci je n'avais rien alors madame
kuperman qui est un visio conférence et
nous en tant pis je veux montrer vous
avez la parole oui monsieur le garde des
sceaux a peut-être tout d'abord masse
aussi bien évidemment à la remarque qui
a été déjà fait par mes collègues
précédemment sur un pic à
l'interrogation où nous pouvons avoir
sur le respect finalement de du travail
du parlement et du bicamérisme et de
l'examen pourtant d'un texte déjà un
conseilleur d'urgence
aucun examen raccourcis sur un texte
pourtant si important mais par une
lecture aux tout cas à minima dans les
deux chambres qui feront bien évidemment
à l'issue la loi et pas avant une
deuxième remarque également son nom le
temps imparti dans le cadre de nos
travaux législatifs
quand nous examinerons de conséquences
puisque de fait nous aurons deux jours
pour légiférer alors certes ce sera un
congé de loi qui ne concentrent que
quelques unités d'articles
officiellement mais quand on prend leur
donnant dans son intégralité ce sont
près de 300 articles de fête sur
lesquels nous sommes amenés à pouvoir
réagir
et même si le sourire vous songé plus
que vous avez dire dans vos propos
introductif bien évidemment nous sommes
ensemble gouvernemental c'est une
gouvernement qui est là mais si cet
ordre du jour donc peut-être pas vous
personnellement et directement notre cas
le gouvernement que vous représentez ici
j'avais une question a peut-être assez
précise et qui concerne
la mise en place de feux qualifie
d'audience unique
vous savez et charmera pu lire les
différentes critiques certain nombre
pour le parallèle avec ce qu'on appelle
la comparution immédiate notamment pour
les publics majeurs
donc j'aurais souhaité monsieur le garde
des sceaux à vous entendre sur comment
est-ce que vous l'envisagez dans son
déroulé dans la protection tout même des
mineurs
on est en tout cas comment éviter que
ces audiences unis si elle devait être
en nombre
en tout cas importante empêche la mise
en place d'une justice que l'on pourrait
qualifier et je la mettrais entre
guillemets alors nous parlons puisque ça
pourriez lui dire que c'est un a priori
mais en tout cas que certains qualifient
d'ores et déjà de justice expéditive
je pense que bien évidence nous avons
tous conscience que l'on prendre de
l'encombrement pardon des juridictions
dans leur diversité d'ailleurs et que tu
sais liste des juridictions mineurs ont
des réductions en do majeur cela en tout
cas ce développement ne peut se faire au
détriment des justiciables
je vous remercie merci avec encore deux
interventions madame de la gontrie et
puis même boyer merci président deux
points le premier concernant la date
d'entrée en vigueur de la réforme
vous avez dit monsieur le ministre que
toute réforme effectivement en général
et on ne peut pas vous donner tort
rencontre son lot d'opposition et de
contestation mais on voit bien que c'est
un nombre très important de
professionnels qui contestent la date
d'entrée en vigueur et par exemple la
présidente de la conférence des
procureurs généraux le 31 mars qui a
indiqué qu'entre en vigueur au 31 mars
était un non-sens donc
au delà de la d'une frilosité d'un
corporatisme que sais-je
on voit bien qu'il ya cette inquiétude
est au fond cette circulaire traduit
sans doute cette nécessité de
précipitation parce que autrement je ne
vois pas très bien pourquoi vous auriez
eu besoin de l'apprendre et afin qu'il
n'y ait pas de malentendu il ne s'agit
pas de d'amour-propre du sénat la
question n'est pas de savoir si nous
sommes offusqués du fait que le sénat
était ignorée lorsque cette circulaire a
été publiée
la question c'est la loi et au fond
philippe à la très bien dit c'est que
les choses sont désormais figée
de fait donc le problème est celui là le
deuxième point concerne plus précisément
et donc on est un petit peu hors champ
du débat sur la justice des mineurs
mais c'est le calendrier qui veut cela
je voulais savoir monsieur le ministre
quel était votre position face au fait
que le procureur général près la cour de
cassation et annoncé l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire avant donc à
votre encontre devant la cour de justice
de la république
après l'avis favorable de la commission
des requêtes vous avez indiqué la
semaine dernière je résume en substance
le moment venu je m'expliquerai je ne
parle absolument pas du fond mais de
votre position de ministre de la justice
je voulais donc savoir si de votre point
de vue
c'était problématique par rapport à
votre situation de garde des sceaux
d'être l'objet d'une information
judiciaire devant la cjr
et si ça n'était pas le cas aujourd'hui
à quel stade de la procédure
pensez vous que cela deviendrait
problématique pour assurer vos fonctions
de garde des sceaux monsieur la gontrie
même boyer et puis ensuite la parole
soit ministre merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je
beaucoup de questions que je souhaitais
posées ont été posées notamment sur
cassiopée sur la ze et les mineurs non
accompagnés
mais monsieur le ministre je souscris à
ce qu'on dit aussi mes collègues jean
pierre sueur philippe bas ou madame de
la gontrie à l'instant sur la position
compliquée dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui on le sait tous
cette réforme doit être mise en place
parce que ça fait longtemps que nous
parlons de l'enfance délinquante je
partage ce point de vue le texte est
ancien il est difficile il a été révisé
une quarantaine de fois mais
malheureusement une fois de plus j'ai
l'impression que le gouvernement cherche
à transformer le parlement en chambre
d'enregistrement d'instruction qui
auraient été données par le président de
la république et je m'attendais mois à
des débats un petit peu plus fouillé
plus long plus ambitieux afin d'avancer
ensemble dans une seule et même
direction c'est à dire trouver un
équilibre entre justice et fermeté on le
sait le temps presse et vous avez décidé
que cette réforme s'appliquerait le 31
mars prochain
et le temps presse tellement que tout
pour vous et actés puisque enfin si j'en
crois le courrier que vous avez adressé
aux professionnels de la justice
et vous vous félicitez des modifications
apportées à ce texte par l'assemblée
nationale
on s'en félicite aussi mais nous sommes
dans un régime bicaméral et on le sait à
chaque projet de loi on nous parle
d'urgence
alors je sais aussi que la pandémie à
bousculer le calendrier
mais on ne peut pas continuer à voir ce
genre de relations avec le parlement en
tout cas à mon sens ça me semble
extrêmement compliqué et c'est ni
orgueil ni aigreur
delà de ma part je pense de la part de
mes collègues sénateurs c'est pas ça
qu'on peut exprimer
parce que le travail a été fait par mes
collègues de façon approfondie avec
sérieux avec avec un fort investissement
et si vous me permettez monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vous
citerai une phrase de georges clemenceau
qui aura marqué quand même l'histoire de
france c'est l'histoire de cette très
belle maison qui disait pendant une
partie de ma vie j'ai eu foi en la
chambre unique comme émanation directe
du sentiment populaire
j'en suis revenue les événements m'ont
appris qu'il faut laisser au peuple le
temps de la réflexion
le temps de la réflexion c'est le sénat
et si vous me permettez monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je
rajouterais c'est aussi la qualité d'un
texte législatif qui a été remanié
tellement de fois que aujourd'hui compte
tenu de l'ambition et de l'ampleur que
chacun à exprimer
je pense que ce serait difficile pour la
population difficile pour les métiers de
la justice est bien de travailler dans
des conditions que nous craignons
peut-être un monsieur michel mercier qui
a demandé la parole après vraiment jeu
de la parole merci monsieur prison
monsieur garde des sceaux j'aurais aimé
avoir votre avis sur le discernement
pour vous avec votre expérience d'avocat
bien bien connu qu'est ce que le
discernement
qu'est ce que le consentement pourriez
vous m'éclairer sur sur ces deux points
et que pensez vous aussi de
l'accompagnement des familles dans
l'éducation de nos jeunes pour que on en
arrive là est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose à nous dire à ce sujet mercy
mercier et bien monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole et vous seuls
monsieur le président dérogeant
peut-être à l'ordre des questions qui
m'ont été posées je vais d'abord
répondre à l'aimable interpellation de
madame la sénatrice de la gontrie
mon crime
madame la sénatrice et d'avoir exercé
mes fonctions exactement comme l'aurait
fait tous mes prédécesseurs dans des
circonstances analogues
j'ai suivi en effet les recommandations
de mon administration
j'ai suivi ma dame les recommandations
de mon administration vous ne pouvez pas
dire que c'est faux vous n'en savez rien
et je le hais je le démontrerai madame
je voudrais vous répondre sans être
interrompu j'ai suivi les
recommandations de mon administration
madame je le démontrerai composée de
magistrats et j'ai saisi pour une simple
enquête
rien de plus rien de moins une autorité
indépendante elle aussi composée de
magistrats pour faire la lumière sur
d'éventuelles fautes déontologiques
pouvant avoir été commises par des
magistrats qui pour certains d'entre eux
n'ont pas déféré aux convocations qui
leur avait été adressé alors puisque
vous préoccuper de mon sort à venir je
voudrais vous dire très calmement très
aimablement et très respectueusement que
si l'objectif de tout cela comme s'est
d'ores et déjà exprimées par certains
c'est de m'interdire de travailler alors
cela en seront pour leurs frais et
d'ailleurs je travaille aujourd'hui avec
vous sur le code de justice pénale des
mineurs
voilà madame la sénatrice ma réponse
elle sera ultérieurement sans doute plus
complète très complète
je n'ai rien à craindre et je suis mais
totalement serein alors maintenant
monsieur le président si
si vous m'y autorise et je vais répondre
aux questions qui vont été posées sur le
code de justice
2e pénale des mineurs d'abord madame
madame la rapporteure vous suggérer un
report de la date d'entrée en vigueur
mais d'une façon paradoxale si vous me
le permettez vous dit
l'un des problèmes c'est la
superposition des dossiers anciennes
procédures avec les dossiers nouvelle
procédure
je voudrais vous faire remarquer que si
nous retardons la mise en oeuvre de
cette loi nouvelle alors il y aura
davantage cette superposition que vous
dénoncez à juste titre car il y aura
davantage encore d'anciens dossiers et
il y aura les dossiers nouveaux
je veux également dire sur sur ces
questions je veux y revenir une fois
pour toutes que dans cette circulaire
qui ne fige en rien personne je ne crois
pas moi sur le questeur que vous soyez
timmy de 400 amendements ont été déposés
à l'assemblée nationale et vous ne vous
interdire ai pas je ne le crois pas une
seule seconde
pas un seul instant de déposer les
amendements vous jugerez utiles et dans
cette circulaire canada dry canada dry
ça ne s'est pas de l'alcool ça y
ressemble quand même sur le président on
a quand même joué un guide extrêmement
important pour les magistrats qui est le
gui de 10 g/j d'entrée de la réforme
un tableau de simulation d orientation
pénale qui règle la question du stock
pardon encore pour ce mot est un tableau
de simulation du besoin d'audience et
pardon de vous dire que là encore mais
dans un domaine un peu différent celui
sur lequel j'ai été interpellé par
madame le la montre et je fais confiance
en l'analyse de mes services
léger j ai fait de magistrats
indépendants ils ont expertisé ils ont
analysé et ils nous ont dit je vous le
dit tout à l'heure je suis tout à fait
transparent avec vous une dizaine de
juridiction fragilisée mais le problème
est réglé
alors ensuite on entend bien les uns et
les autres qu'il y ait quelques
réticences qu'on a du mal à envisager
une autre procédure
moi quand j'étais avocat qu'une nouvelle
procédure arriver il fallait d'abord que
je la lisent ça me contraignait un peu
et parfois j'ai dit il ya une inflation
mais ici la réalité c'est que cette loi
elle est attendue depuis 2007 le nombre
de commissions on aura l'occasion de
rappeler tout cela bon nous aurons des
débats très complet je vais également
rassuré monsieur le questeur c'est ces
trois jours de débat prévus donc vous
aurez toute latitude pour me
m'interroger avec la minutie l'observer
le le pragmatisme la minutie du
chirurgien le pragmatisme de la sécurité
sociale je vous connais rien ne vous
échappera deux ou trois jours de débat
là dessus
donc vous vous êtes rassurés vous faites
celui qui ne va pas osé mais vous aurez
tout est naturellement et est pardon
pardon vous oserez tout ce que vous
estimez utiles à l'amélioration de ce
texte et je vous entendrez d'ailleurs je
veux dire que dans les 400 amendements
qui ont été déposés il ya un certain
nombre d'amendements que nous avons
retenu que j'ai retenu le jld moi je
n'avais pas une position très arrêtées
et de la discussion avec les
parlementaires il faut que ils en
sortent forcément quelque chose j'en ai
retiré une position qui était inverse
donc là dessus je tiens à vous rassurer
mais je pense je sais au fond de vous
vous l'êtes déjà nous nous nous aurons
ce débat et enfin pour répondre
complètement ces questions mais c'est
votre question a été envisagée par
d'autres notamment par monsieur le
sénateur sûr il ya aussi ce que nous
avons à mener dans les juridictions
je voulais dit tout à l'heure soixante
douze magistrats ont été affectés 1er
septembre 2020
sans greffier de 152 emplois nouveaux
créés en 2000 22,86 éducateurs qui
viennent d'être recrutés donc nous nous
avons fait cela
e à la suite de l'analyse conduite par
les services de la chancellerie
ils en ont strictement aucun intérêt
voiliers ont à nous dire que les
juridictions sont prêtes si elles ne le
sont pas parce que ce serait d'une
certaine façon une catastrophe que
d'envisager un texte est un beau texte
moi j'en suis absolument convaincu
inapplicable voilà je pense
la première réponse à la question vous
faisait monsieur le sénateur sur vous
êtes inquiet de ce que nous allons faire
je veux je devrais dire de ce que nous
devons faire à la suite de la décision
du conseil constitutionnel de 2 octobre
vous savez que je souhaitais que l'on
examine cette question pour des raisons
on va le dire technique
ça n'a pas été possible je travaille
donc activement pour que nous soyons
évidemment en conformité avec ce que le
conseil constitutionnel a décidé vous
donner une date
[Musique]
alors on essaie de trouver le vecteur
législatif pour introduire ce recours
effectif dans notre droit
on y travaille je n'ai pas encore de
réponse je n'en jeu non je n'en non je
n'ai pas répondu ou plein le seul garde
des sceaux ce n'est pas un peu après par
la carte est désormais mais comment vous
le dire que simplement les adverbes sont
utiles ils le convient urgemment il faut
répondre à ça je vous en dirai davantage
vous reçoit bientôt d'ailleurs demain
pour évoquer une autre question
j'espère vous donner la réponse sur wii
il suffit de demander plus
il suffit de mangue et sur les
responsabilités
bon les magistrats devront
systématiquement motivé le discernement
du mineur de moins de 13 ans pour
engager des poursuites
j'ai deux guinées tout à l'heure vous
pouvez en effet leur prof à leurs
proches non non on a le droit mais mais
merci merci monsieur merci monsieur le
sénateur n'est pas que c'est une liberté
fondamentale mais enfin tout de même
j'ai de l'île et c'était ma façon
d'exprimer votre scepticisme quand vous
disiez que c'est parfaitement tranché en
droite internationale non c'est un vrai
débat toutes les législations ne sont
pas les mêmes
13 ans on peut discuter de cela ensuite
le caractère refera gabelous
irréfragable oui une cohérence et il ya
une logique on s'expliquera là dessus
mais vous la connaissez déjà
au fond le discernement c'est l'analyse
du juge
et moi je ne prends pas non plus si vous
voulez la décision du juge qui est une
décision sous l'égide de cette
philosophie de l'ordonance de 45
c'est fait pour les enfants pas contre
les enfants et le débat que nous avons
eu notamment avec certains c'était de
dire qu' il n'y avait plus il n'y avait
plus d'enfants contre le crime était
grave
comme si c'est à l'aune de la gravité
d'un crime que l'on mesurait le
discernement tout ça vous le savez c'est
bien plus subtil que ça il faut fixer un
âge
évidemment il ya ceux qui vous diront
mais après c'est pas bien fallait 14
d'autres vous diront 12 bon ça fera des
parties naturellement du du débat
parlementaire mais en réalité il faut
laisser aux juges le soin d'analyser le
discernement et ça répond pardonner
membres est menacée mattrick un peu
votre question vous me demandiez de mon
expérience d'avocat
j'ai été assez souvent au début devant
tribunal pour enfants quand j'étais
jeune avocat bon j'ai vu des gamins très
jeune très mûrs et puis j'ai vu des
gamins
bien deux plus âgés sans aucune maturité
et sans aucun discernement et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faisait c'est me
semble-t-il au juge est un professionnel
de l'enfance le soin de fixer les choses
il faut lui l'excès ni laisser me
semble-t-il beaucoup de flexibilité mais
ces sénateurs le conte dont le jet alors
sur l'audience unique pardon à
l'irréversible l'audience unique
voilà ce que je peux vous dire d'abord
elle est exceptionnelle elle est
enserrée dans des conditions qui sont
très stricte et elle est réversible
c'est à dire qu'à tout moment on peut
revenir à cette procédure classique et
d'ailleurs on fait bien de m'interpeller
j'allais oublier de vous répondre et
vous avez bien fait de de m'interpeller
sur cette question parce que c'est une
des contestations que l'on a entendu qui
a été repris certains ont poussé des
cris d'orfraie en disant que c'était
beaucoup plus répressif
c'est une procédure l'audience unis tout
à fait exceptionnelle nous en débattrons
il après conditions et le juge a
toujours la main là dessus il peut
toujours si j'ose dire revenir en
arrière considérer que ce choix
l'audience unique n'est pas le bon choix
c'est une véritable garantie pour
l'enfant mais c'est le sénateur jean
yves le conte j'adore échanger avec vous
mais là vous me posez une question
pardonnez moi à quel je ne peux pas
répondre
j'y répondrai ultérieurement sans aucun
doute je n'ai pas la prétention d'être
omniscient je le regrette infiniment au
quotidien bioéthique ça n'était pas le
sujet si j'ose dire l'ordre du jour
pardon je ne veux pas fuir la question
ou mela reposerait le moment venu et
j'essaierai d'y répondre
mais si si si si si si bien sûr et puis
bien sûr oui oui oui oui bien monsieur
le questeur bas bon je vous ai déjà ont
amplement amplement répondu et je veux
une fois encore vous rassurer sur votre
pleine et entière capacité amender ce
texte et non mais est considéré au fond
que les choses se réfugier parce que
j'aurai dressait une circulaire canada
dry aux magistrats et que ça vous
interdirait aux fonds de bouger le texte
c'est assez spéciaux comme argument
pardon de vous le dire ainsi avec cette
liberté
c'est curieux non ce que l'on a envoyé
ses eaux font les grandes lignes les
très grandes lignes puisque l'une des
raisons de de discussion 7,7 en lte est
nous dit-on l'impréparation en dépit du
fait que j'ai rassuré les uns et les
autres fassent respon sur les moyens que
nous y avons mis sur l' expertise des
services sur la volonté pour les
services de évidemment d'aller vers une
loi qui est applicable sinon tout cela
n'aurait strictement aucun sens ni moi
ni vous ni magistrats non le goût de
l'effort
inutile madame la sénatrice terre bien
je je je vais essayer de répondre je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
vous dites
évidemment que si on pouvait détecter
plus vite avant si on pouvait empêcher
louis mais pour autant pour autant qu'il
me soit permis de vous dire que il ya
des textes relatifs bien sûr la
protection de l'enfance 2007 2016 je
voulais rappelle pour mémoire ils ne
sont pas abrogés par la loi que nous
examinerons il
ils sont toujours là bien sûr et donc
ces textes là ont vocation à s'appliquer
ce qui rejoint d'ailleurs eu une autre
question qui m'a été posée tout à
l'heure sur le parcours pénal au thon et
l'analyse madame la sénatrice vais rien
vous faites de l'article
sans 12-14 en réalité ceux qui sont déjà
placés à la zone la combinaison des
dispositions civiles et pénales aux
vocations
évidemment à se poursuivre ça n'est pas
exclusif c'est possiblement cumulatif
tant que je tiens à vous rassurer
pleinement et est d'ailleurs
heureusement parce que sinon ça n'aurait
ça n'aurait pas de sens d'affirmer que
cette loi
privilégier l'éducatif est au fond un
nous verrions l'éducatif balayé et la
protection balayé au profit si j'ose
dire de la répression ça n'aurait
évidemment pas de sens sur sur le
tribunal de police
cinquième classe devant juge des enfants
les autres restent donc une halle de
police nous avons eu des tas d'état
d'état d'un amendement présenté par la
france est soumise qui souhaitait
absolument que ce contentieux du
tribunal de police bascule vers le juge
des enfants dont on nous dit déjà qu'il
serait surchargé bon alors nous avons
essayé d'expliquer à la représentation
nationale
l'assemblée nous avons été me
semble-t-il entendu il fallait pas
modifier les choses il ya un certain
nombre de précautions qui sont prises
notamment en matière de droits de la
défense puisque ça nous verrons tout
cela est et est au fond il était
important de préserver ses équilibres
j'ai également été interrogé par madame
cécile que kuperman madame la sénatrice
pardon pour cette coupable hésitation
qu'est ce que la procédure de saisine du
tpe au fin d'audience unique
alors c'est une procédure j'ai déjà dit
à monsieur le sénateur sur dérogatoire à
la procédure de mise à l'épreuve
éducative décidée par le parquet c'est
l'hypothèse qui permet le placement en
détention provisoire des le déferrement
en ouverture d'information le mineur est
jugé dans un délai de dix jours à trois
mois sur la culpabilité et la sanction
est le tpe ne peut prononcer tout
mesures éducatives ou peine le tpe peut
d'ailleurs à sortir une peine ferme
d'emprisonnement d'un mandat de dépôt
sens
condition de quantum ou de récidive et
nous verrons les conditions pour
recourir à cette procédure
exceptionnelle et je redis ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure à monsieur le
sénateur sueur il ya toujours la
possibilité de revenir en arrière vers
la procédure qui sera la procédure
classique
si vous me permettez ce mot madame la
sénatrice boyer j'entends ce que vous me
dites j'entends résonner les mots de
clemenceau trois jours de débats en
séance publique le 26 janvier prochain
l'urgence c'est aussi l'urgence du
justiciable
la justice des mineurs aujourd'hui n'est
plus adapté et jeudi qu'une justice qui
intervient pro ouais ça ça ça revient
pardon a enfin c'est cohérent avec ce
que nous avons appelé la justice de
proximité j'aurai l'occasion de décliner
de re décliner il n'est pas cohérent
qu'un gamin soit jugée trop tardivement
ça n'a aucun sens donc ça aussi c'est
l'urgence
l'amélioration de la procédure pénale
applicables aux plus fragiles aux
mineurs et beaucoup de professionnels
nous aurons l'occasion de dire cela on
va pas faire du culturisme jaillir
politique en disant nous avons plus de
gens favorables que il n'ya de gens
contre il ya des gens contre il ya des
gens qui sont favorables chez les
professionnels il ya une très très
grande consultation les juges des
enfants étaient consultés afin nous
reverrons tout ça j'aurai l'honneur
d'expliquer tout ça c'est une réalité
mais les professionnels dans leur
ensemble réclame cette réforme même s'il
ya un certain nombre de points
névralgiques dont je redis ils ont été
pris en considération par les services
voilà monsieur le président ce que trop
longuement
je voulais vous dire aimer n'a alors il
menace sujets très importants et menace
son démineurs accompagnés ou non si vous
me permettez ce recours si ils sont
justiciables de ce code de justice
pénale des mineurs
ce n'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais
je pourrais développer bien sûr ce que
notamment nous sommes allés faire au
maroc
le véritable problème des menacer leur
identification
parce qu'il ya des maynats qui sont des
majeurs dans la compagnie il ya des
maynats marocain par exemple qui sont
des majeurs non accompagnés algériens ou
d'une autre nationalité
et la grande question pour nous c'était
d'obtenir un certain nombre d'assurances
pour que l'on puisse identifier ces
gamins bien sûr et la vérification a
également été été conduite par les
services de la qualité des structures
d'accueil qui se trouve au maroc et ces
structures ont été visitées elles ont
été regardées de près ainsi d'ailleurs
que le service de protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse au maroc et ce qui m'est
revenue de ses différentes visites qui
ont été faits avec le magistrat de
liaison sur place c'est que ces deux
grandes qualités mais ça change
évidemment la donne si nous avons la
possibilité de travailler avec les
autorités marocaines sur
l'identification qu'il ya un certain
nombre de choses que nous avons proto
colisée et un certain nombre de
techniques auxquelles nous avons songé
par exemple la vérification du portable
si vous avez le préfixe marocain 20 x
jours vous avez compris qu'il s'agit
vraisemblablement d'un émana marocain
alors peut-être pas mineur mais voilà et
puis nous nous voulons vraiment régler
cette question mais de façon très
générale les mène à sont justiciables du
code de justice pénale des mineurs
enfin le jld gilles des spécialisée avec
des formations particulières j'y
reviendrai sans doute parce que c'était
ça faisait partie des nombreuses
interrogations qui ont été celles des
députés
gld spécialisés pour éviter justement
comment dirais je
le procès qui pourrait être fait procès
inéquitable dans la mesure où on a
considéré moi j'ai longuement réfléchi
sur cette question mais finalement on a
considéré que c'était peut-être plus
conforme à la jurisprudence de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme voilà
monsieur le président je pense avoir
répondu à peu près à toutes les
questions qui m'ont été posées
merci monsieur le ministre je crois que
monsieur bart et que demander la parole
24 y est peut-être
merci monsieur le président je ne veux
pas buzzé de cette parole que vous me
rendais je voudrais et vous dire
monsieur le garde des sceaux que j'ai
mal dû formuler la question tout à
l'heure si j'en juge par la réponse que
vous m'avez fait à deux reprises
je n'ai pas d'inquiétude sur notre
capacité à exercer notre droit
d'amendement à vrai dire ce droit ne
nous est pas concédé par les
gouvernements nous tirons de la
constitution et nous n'avons aucune
espèce d'inhibition face à son exercice
cela va de soi même si vous avez bien
voulu nous rassurer sur cette latitude
que ne manqueront pas d'exercer notre
préoccupation c'est plutôt comment faire
en sorte que le jeu normal du processus
législatif puisse aboutir et nous
l'espérons un accord en commission mixte
paritaire qui prennent en compte le
travail du sénat si le débat est à
l'avance fermée par le fait que la
chancellerie a déjà décidé ce que serait
le dispositif final
j'entends ce que je lui dit et je
l'interprète comme un propos destinés à
nous rassurer
je crois que vous êtes attachés comme
nous un débat de bonne foi et je
n'accepte tout à fait l'auguré
je note l'ouverture que vous faites par
avance à nos amendements et la preuve
par neuf viendra dans le débat
parlementaire et dans les travaux de la
commission mixte paritaire
[Musique]